restaurants make up four percent of our
gdp
and employ 11 million people and 16
million people if you look at the other
people in the supply chain
when coven 19 struck it affected all
corners of the economy
but the restaurant industry was hit
especially hard
the pandemic has forced us to move a lot
faster and ahead than we initially had
planned to
the unemployment rate is twice the
national average and we're at risk of
losing permanently tens of thousands of
restaurants
the restaurant industry as a whole has
lost an estimated 290 billion dollars in
revenue from 2020 to 2021 with
approximately 90 000 restaurants across
the united states closing permanently
as the pandemic continues restaurants
are forced to constantly adapt and
evolve
there's an immense amount of opportunity
for
collective innovation and collaboration
as we move through this phase and into a
recovery phase and i'm excited about
what we can create and how we can stitch
this industry and our communities back
together better than they ever were
before
so
which restaurants will survive and what
will restaurants look like in this new
world
free pandemic 2019 that has a lot of
great memories we actually opened fourth
quarter of 2019 we had you know a full
staff we were actually becoming like a
family getting into the flow of things
during the holidays we were extra busy
because we were new we were rocking
business was good it was looking likely
that you know i'd maybe be able to start
paying myself at the end of that summer
at the beginning it was easier to have
the mindset of okay we're just getting
through this week by week you know month
by month and then towards the end it
started getting really tiring you know
there's only so much of um oh we're just
hanging on hanging on that you can do
and we did and we i felt like we we did
a great job through all of that but at
the end i was starting to lose sleep i
was starting to
be concerned because we were so new we
didn't have a lot of cash flow
when march 15th came
there was a lot of trepidation just the
fear of the unknown existed i was
paralyzed we were devastated no one had
experienced that before
that was a dire moment for me to say
that you know i don't know when you're
gonna come back to work i had no answers
no one provided us with guidance
they really struggled on trying to
figure out okay can we do a takeout menu
how are we gonna do that they were so
focused on the customer experience
inside the four walls of the restaurant
and shifting to okay we need to make
revenue we need to figure out a delivery
platform and a takeout menu
usually the larger chains that had
invested in digital that had invested in
a mobile order and pay app or some sort
of online ordering they were able to
pivot much quicker than those that had
not invested in technology and had not
invested in a digital customer
experience or an ordering platform
it was a day by day learning process it
was a learning curve every single day
unfortunately some of these things you
know cost money you know they require
financial resources that we simply did
not have all of those shifts and those
decisions were made independently for
different restaurants and depending on
where you were on the spectrum of
technology comfortability safety and the
local guidelines and so
you had different restaurants doing
different things
even if these adaptations were applied
restaurant owners still faced supply
chain issues labor shortages and losses
of revenue
[Music]
restaurants were struggling getting
certain products they were struggling
getting certain meats and then there
were certain paper products whether it
be straws or paper or so that was a huge
hindrance you can't just flip a switch
back on and have all the products that
you need immediately flowing through the
supply chain and so restaurants are
faced with increased costs on products
ranging from proteins to cooking oils to
even things as simple as a to-go box
we are in a massive labor shortage we
have a supply chain shortage in terms of
actual goods and services that we're
able to procure i've had to change my
menu so many times because i'm not able
to procure everything that's needed for
certain recipes i would say from staff
we need quality staff and we need
training for our staff as a result
quality does suffer on many ends and the
level of service you do have does suffer
a little bit
help also came in the form of federal
assistance the restaurant revitalization
fund the restaurant revitalization fund
provides debt-free support in the amount
of annual revenue loss from 2019 and
2020 with special provisions for
businesses that opened in 2019 and 2020.
the restaurant revitalization fund
grants were awarded to businesses whose
primary purpose is that they are a place
where people gather
to consume food or drink so your
neighborhood coffee shop your favorite
date night restaurant would qualify then
they needed to demonstrate that they
lost revenue in 2020 and they did that
by providing things like tax returns and
point-of-sale reports we were able to
secure
28.6
billion dollars
to be able to help these independent
restaurants
over a hundred thousand grants were
distributed
but passing a bill and actually getting
the money into the hands of struggling
restaurateurs are two different things
as soon as the application went live
i got my application in within moments
and then i got an approval
and then i got a letter stating that
because of a lawsuit that had happened
the sba was not able to pay out those
funds the need far outstripped that the
fund was basically exhausted in just a
few days it just
felt like a slap across the face and
wondering what's next and how are we
going to be able to keep up with this
demand and grow
without cash flow we have no cash
reserves
we sound a bit like a broken record
constantly calling our members of
congress and telling them that
restaurants aren't okay despite
appearances
well bear in mind we've been dealing
with the near collapse of the economy
there are massive needs that have
developed all across the country for
health there's a lot of demand there's a
lot of competition there are over 60
billion dollars of needs that remain
when the fund was exhausted so what
we're trying to do is replenish it so
that everybody who was eligible and
applied would be able to be taken care
of we have a situation where
restaurants are still dealing with the
up and down enclosures increased costs
hesitant consumers so they really need
financial assistance to give them the
foundation to be able to continue to
operate and to continue to recover as we
ride out this wave if you drive anywhere
in the u.s and you see a restaurant
there's going to be a sign outside that
says help wanted or that they're
enticing people with a 15 per hour
incentive or some some restaurants have
gone to 17 an hour because they can't
staff their restaurants
we have one member of our coalition
who has over 1.5 million dollars in
deferred rent payments you're not going
to pay that off with just one busy
saturday
and at the end of the day it's not all
about the money
health is more important than business
at the end of the day and if we need to
shut down because it's saving lives
we'll do it that's why we stayed takeout
only because we were too small to space
people out appropriately
but that's scary
despite the obstacles and the delta
variant threatening to beat back the
progress they've made some restaurant
owners remain cautiously optimistic for
the future
i have a lot of trepidation about the
fall in the winter because we all know
that the more people come indoors the
more closer contact you become with
people that the virus can spread faster
the pandemic happening gave me a chance
to kind of step back and reevaluate our
operation you know the kitchen's very
very small it's a two-person kitchen and
just to kind of see how it is from their
standpoint and you know just find ways
to be more efficient
i don't think that the restaurants will
go to a fully automated platform i do
feel like there will be a healthy
balance as they try to figure out the
labor and wage shortage
between automation and human labor
we need consumers you know obviously to
show up and support our small businesses
but we need patience and understanding
and if a restaurant is going to require
you to wear a mask it's not what they
want to do that's not fun for them it's
what they need to do to make sure that
their employees aren't sick
or that the economy doesn't shut down
again
we do need them to continue
dining out in any way that they feel
comfortable whether that's sitting on a
patio whether it's purchasing to go food
going inside dining which in some places
is quite safe and lovely it's also to be
patient these restaurants may not have
your favorite dish right now because the
supply chain isn't allowing them to
purchase the ingredients they need
also you might notice that prices have
increased and there's only so much you
can
squash down a menu price when everything
that is going into
making your dinner whether that's the
ingredients or the folks preparing your
food
has a price
the restaurant industry has stepped up
they've provided critical service
they've been innovative and in many
cases they have stepped up to help
people who otherwise wouldn't have
access to this healthy food
restaurants are going to be front and
center of any sort of economic recovery
they deserve our support
one of the silver linings that you don't
see when you're dining
is that these independent restaurants
across the country have always been the
places where you go when you need help
whether it's
donating something to the little league
team or the school auction
or just creating an incredible
environment where you can go hang out
with your girlfriends after a really bad
day they've always been giving
and this is the first time that they've
really had to ask for help and i think
that this community has found their
voice
and found how powerful their voices can
be in creating change not just for them
but for their communities
[Music]
you